hey you can ask a chain hey you can ask
wow thanks Maddox to you for that
amazing intro you rock now let's get on
with the wonderful West gotcha questions
baby they're crossing wait least
favorite food is cucumbers and pickles I
toss boo who wants to know if I like
babies and actually yes I do like babies
and as long as I'm not sitting next to
them on an extremely long flight and
they're crying the entire time
Terra Nicole wants to know at sport I
played in high school I played softball
and volleyball what sports did slash do
you guys play simply Freddy wants to
know what my scary face is now is this
face that I'm supposed to scare you or
is it a face that I'm supposed to be
scared
actually yes I think you guys are very
pretty I have actually touched the
Stanley Cup tweet acrostic if I referred
what food would I be at be a passion
fruit
actually I am a passion fruit hey guys
it's me I just seen what Vaughn is my
logo on Twitter
it's called cheeseburger go figure JPL
wants to know if I ever bought anything
that I've seen on TV like an infomercial
yeah actually I have I bought the shake
weight and it was a big waste of money
just yeah
no bad idea I got the OMG and new
pillows from through boo comm check
looks impressive cool 21 Eclair wants to
know what my horoscope thing he is and
if I'm left or right-handed I'm a Pisces
and I'm left-handed in the last episode
I told you it is how tall I am or
actually how short I am my 5/3 and
pretty much everyone was like Justine
I'm 12 and I am boy you look so much
taller on the internet yeah I know I'm
sorry I can't help it if somebody loved
a whole bag of food on my doorstep would
I eat it if I was hungry
no if it was a cheeseburger yeah
definitely I don't care who left it
there I would definitely eat it but if
it was just a salad or something not so
tasty I'm just gonna leave it no Steve
doesn't actually have a restraining
order on me yet crusty tater tots or
french fries french fries Christina
wants to know if I have a rape whistle
and actually yeah I do if I could name
my own Island what would I name
I don't know
hmm I'm gonna know what brand of shampoo
you use because your hair always look so
good
hmm something about that video was
slightly creepy I'm not sure if it was
the wink at the end or the fact that you
don't want to know what kind of shampoo
I use either way it's this kind and a
huge shout out to these two awesome
cheerleaders in the sky cheer hey yeah
yeah yeah thank you guys so much for
watching this episode of ask IJ don't
forget to subscribe to my youtube
channel and check out my other youtube
channels for more wonderful fun videos